bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques qui est ce que votre
magazine culture sur saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs alors tout de
suite le sommaire pour ce mercredi 30
septembre
thierry taran professeur au lycée henri
matisse de trappes et comédien produit
depuis trois ans sur paris la pièce à
succès le coach il est en plateau pour
nous parler de son actualité la
préparation de talons aiguilles et
crampons qui sera joué le 14 octobre au
palace toujours à paris nour el yakine
louise comédien dans la compagnie déclic
théâtre a imaginé une rencontre
surprenante pour ouvrir et saison la
jeune génération de comédiens
professionnels défis les plus anciens
lui aussi nous en dira plus dans
quelques instants
electro deluxe était à la batterie à
guyancourt vendredi dernier groupe fondé
en 2001 mûri au jazz au funk au rap et à
la soul a assuré le spectacle entre
cuivres puissants et chanteur
charismatique
c'est donc une émission qui fait la part
belle au théâtre aujourd'hui avec nos
invités nous rallier qui nourrissent
comédiens professionnels et responsables
du secteur un pro de la compagnie déclic
théâtre bonsoir et thierry taran
comédien et producteur mais aussi
professeur enseignant au lycée henri
matisse de trappes bonsoir nour vous
auriez souhaité avoir un professeur qui
à côté et comédien au lycée comment
pardon est ce que vous auriez souhaité
avoir au lycée à un professeur qui en
parallèle et comedia et ben oui je leur
ai souhaité puis je les lui la chance
d'en avoir
donc voilà je peux me vanter de ça alors
c'est pas donné à tout le monde c'est
sûr mais mais effectivement ce qui est
plaisant je pense c'est que
effectivement il ya une approche un peu
différente
surtout quand on va aborder des textes
voilà de théâtre et genre de choses
il essaye de faire justement preuve de
leur savoir faire alors thierry tassez
vous dévoilerez votre spécialité
n'aurait liakine comédiens
professionnels on lui disait dans la
compagnie déclic théâtre compagnie que
l'on ne présente plus mais quand même
compagnie créée en 1993 par papy attrape
pas piquer en 2013 a été nommé chevalier
des arts et lettres dont l'essentiel des
activités est axée autour des matchs
d'improvisation théâtrale ce que vous
pourriez nous expliquer ce qu'est
très simplement c'est une rencontre en
fait entre deux équipes mixtes avec des
garçons et des filles autour de thèmes
en fait qui sont proposés par un arbitre
et à la fin de chaque improvisation le
public est invité à voter donc c'est lui
qui est le déterminant de la dramaturgie
du spectacle en donnant son vote et du
coup ils votent pour l'une ou l'autre
équipe en fonction de ce qu'il a préféré
alors simplement mouren yakine vous
venez justement vous présenter le
spectacle deux matchs d'improvisation
que vous avez monté avec mélanie le
moigne pour ouvrir cette saison c'est un
choix un peu surprenant parce qu'il
s'agit d'opposer le 2 octobre prochain à
la mairie attrape un conflit inter
générationnel entre les jeunes et les
anciens alors pourquoi ce choix
déjà pour l'affiché l'histoire de
pouvoir faire revenir les plus anciens à
la compagnie et puis le les puits faire
voilà que tout le monde en profite que
les clés que les habitants qui
connaissent ces joueurs là puisse les
retrouver
et puis aussi à le côté un peu défi des
plus jeunes de d'aller titiller leur
père en plus ce qui est intéressant
c'est que voilà il ya 20 ans d'histoire
dans la compagnie déclic théâtre
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que ceux qui
ont ce qu'ils vont jouer dans l'équipe
des jeunes ont pas forcément été formés
parce qu'ils ont rencontrés voilà
vendredi soir et du coup c'est un petit
peu l'occasion voilà de de les mettre
ensemble à l'honneur dans la patinoire
ce soir parce que vous disiez donc plus
de vingt ans de compagnie c'est plus de
dix mille jeunes qui ont été affûté une
écurie de renom donc notamment jamel
debbouze sophia aram à queue longue at
ou qui sera présent aux red bull et bien
mois déjà et puis et puis plein d'autres
qui sera présent un bain on va retrouver
papy qui sera là avec jb qui sont les co
fondateurs de la de la compagnie
stéphane guillet aussi qui viendra
spécialement de rochefort pour ce match
là
on va avoir aussi virginie britten qui
est championne du monde d'improvisation
avec l'équipe de france on aura mélanie
lemoine voilà qui est notre directrice
artistique qui sera sur scène en
particulier pour les jeunes non il n'y a
aucun enjeu c'est une soirée pour le
plaisir de se retrouver à trappes en
famille voilà avec
des personnes qui font la compagnie
aujourd'hui qu'ils soient jeunes ou
anciens voilà l'idée c'est puis l'idée
c'est aussi de montrer aux plus jeunes
parce qu'il ya tous nos adhérents qui
vont venir donc ceux qui ont lancé une
improvisation aujourd'hui leur proposer
de venir à la merise pour aussi voir que
tout ça ne tient pas qu'à une poignée de
personnes mais effectivement rappelé un
petit peu l'histoire de notre compagnie
puis à cette passation de pouvoirs aussi
entre papilles et moi en l'occurrence /
/ / la compagnie est sûre sur l'aspect
artistique autour de l'improvisation
c'est aussi voilà l'occasion de le
remettre encore une fois à l'honneur et
puis et puis montrer à la population
qu'on est les dignes héritiers de de ce
que lui a proposée voilà de ce qu'il a
instaurées attrapé puis lui montrer que
voilà on continue à mettre en avant à
mettre en avant l' improvisation
théâtrale sur sur le territoire alors
avant de poursuivre l'entretien nous
allons partir faire un petit tour du
côté de saint germain en laye pour la
28e édition de l'estivale c'est un
festival qui promeut la chanson
francophone
norel yakine thierry est ce que vous
avez déjà eu l'occasion de vous rendre à
l'estival qui ouvre non plus non alors
c'est l'occasion de les découvrir
ensemble
l'image d'elodie lemoine 28e édition
pour l'estival de saint germain en laye
un festival éclectique qui défend la
chanson francophone sous toutes ses
formes jusqu'au 10 octobre
on est en france que je pense que la
plupart des jeunes qui viennent au
spectacle aime bien aussi comprendre ce
que leur disent les artistes on l'a bien
vu là avec
alexis hk ou marché là où il retrouve
pour le début de ce festival dont il ya
des paroles qu elles sont intelligentes
et qu'elles peuvent apporter quelque
chose aux jeunes et avec une belle
poésie on préfère que ça soit en
français 18 concerts pour faire
découvrir de jeunes talents qui
partagent l'affiché aux côtés de
célébrités telles que barbara hendricks
brigitte alexis hk mj les frérots de la
vega ou encore daphné et clarika dans
leur spectacle en poésie et en chansons
ivresse et les évasions quoi l'évasion
les tourbillons les ouïes les vrais
amoureux
ouais c'est ça c'est un thème très très
très vaste en fait et très musique étant
déjà qu'elle aimerait également dans le
fond dans le propos de l'eia de la
transgression sinon les dresse donc donc
c'est toujours intéressant voilà c'est
c'est un délit bulliciosa plein mauvaise
ça bouillonne s'est passé en mouvement
voilà way
à
tous les ans l'équipe de l'estival met
en lumière le travail d'une association
caritative ou humanitaire en lui
apportant un soutien médiatique et
financier par la vente de produits
dérivés du festival cette année c'est
les bouchons d'amour savez les petits
bouchons qu'on récupère qui permettent à
des jeunes handicapés d'avoir un
fauteuil ou d'avoir par exemple un chien
qui qui vient s'occuper de 50,2 je crois
un mission pour la personne handicapée
et à paris
votre 2
cros chico le jour on l'a rencontré 6e
d'europe il ya deux ans de trois ans
vous êtes vous déjà essayé au match
d'improvisation absolument pas ça ne
vous a jamais tenté
on a fait des exercices quand on était à
florence sur sur l'impro comme ça on en
fait suffisamment entre nous quand on
répète ça c'est drôle
une partie assez marrante mais non c'est
un exercice difficile pour montrer
quelles sont les qualités requises
justement pour l'improvisation à théâtre
là je pense il faut déjà être hyper
créatif
bah oui c'est ça et puis avoir enfin
mettre mettre son imaginaire à plat
auprès du public c'est à dire que c'est
faux être condamnés puis surtout faut
avoir la capacité d'écouter les
propositions et d'être capable de
répondre de manière positive pour pour
faire avancer l'histoire
est ce une équipe s'il ne peut pas se
tirer le chapeau plus qu'un autre parce
que sinon l'équipe ne marche pas
fonctionne plus du tout vent que ça a
besoin là cette créativité des vraiment
d'être concentré avec avec cette
spontanéité en pensant qu'ils utilisent
derrière et ça peut tout partir en live
si violent qu'il veut vraiment faire
plus que les deux autres séances sur des
équipes de doubles du mans et ça c'est
dommage
alors thierry taran vous êtes professeur
de sciences médico sociales
c'est bien ça ou c'est henri matisse la
trappe vous êtes également comédien et
producteur
vous avez fait les cours florent 2002 à
2004 oui alors vous n'avez jamais eu
envie de choisir entre votre profession
de professeur et alors il ya 2 il ya
deux choses c'est ça fait très longtemps
je voulais faire du théâtre donc ça fait
20 ans quasiment vingt ans que je baigne
dans le métier
mais avant de d'être comédien ce que je
voulais c'est une soupe est dépendant
financièrement donc j'ai été affirmé
donc à partir mon jeu mais si j'assume
et j'ai pris le pari de pouvoir être
d'être comédien après voilà une fois que
j'ai fait une bonne bien 15 en tant
qu'infirmier j'étais embauché par
l'éducation nationale est là et bien là
être comédien être comédien est prof
il ya beaucoup de ressemblances quand
même s'il est en représentation leurs
positions alors visualiser depuis trois
ans la pièce le coach qui est un des
plus gros cartons parisien au théâtre
alambic
on ne regarde tout de suite un extrait
ces résultats l'imputation des taxes
parafiscales propres au mois de mai je
suis professeur ses lada
si je te suis qui me fit même si je te
fuis du moci boxing day
alalala vous avez dit si je suis tu me
suis elle avait habité vanessa au
restaurant je suis vanessa alors le
coach c'est l'histoire de quelqu'un de
gentil peut-être trop gentil qui a
besoin de se faire quoi tueur pour
apprendre à dire non tout à fait de voir
cette pièce au théâtre alanguie alors
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
non parce que ça fait trois ans mais que
le public est toujours là donc au reste
c'est plus de 120 dates dans toute la
france ils ont maintenant à l'étranger
aussi belgique suisse maroc encore des
dates de rendu pour 2010 est donc ça
fonctionne très très bien c'est les
grosses salles donc ses papattes arrêté
alors le coach n'est pas votre première
pièce vous avez également produit talons
aiguilles et crampons que l'on pouvait
voir au théâtre elle implique également
de décembre 2012 à janvier 2013 où il
était question d'une jeune journaliste
sportive qui démarrait aux côtés de la
star des commentateurs tv pour la
représenter à nouveau au palace à paris
le 14 octobre prochain c'est un théâtre
2000 places
j'imagine que la pièce vous a été
demandé et plébiscité par le public
oui alors d'abord le faut savoir que
talons aiguilles et crampons et le coach
ont été écrits par bruno bachot qui joue
dans les deux pièces et dont le coach le
film a été tirée de la pièce avec
richard berry jean paul rouve vainqueur
bruno a scénarisé et bruno donc on voit
sur à gauche sur ce raid est ce un
budget marcellin l'autre comédienne qui
va jouer cette pièce a été le début
d'autres aventures puisqu'on a commencé
à avignon avec j'en suis à mon dixième
avignon et bruno et on a eu cette chance
extraordinaire c'est d'abord d'avoir
rencontré fiel qui ont adoré la pièce et
qui s'amuse ouvert toutes les portes et
dans ce métier là la rencontre est
primordiale et ça nous a permis de
pouvoir démarrer dans des salles plus
importante est de pouvoir lancer le
coach derrière puisque talon aiguille
est un autre verture pour pour nos
pièces là et nos pièces futur ce qu'on
en a d'autres qui arrivent
une autre surtout qui arrivent et le
talons aiguilles et crampons a été
demandée par par un grand groupe
parisien qui était mieux le voir les
peintures de paris pour les cités parce
que ça fait aussi partie des mecs comme
ça et ils ont eu nous ont demandé de
faire cette pièce on travaille déjà avec
le coach et donc on a fait on fait
talons aiguilles et crampons pour eux
qui ont eux aussi au public ses
compilateurs zogota mais c'est complet
prochain au palace alors nous règne à
kintélé je sais que vous connaissez
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
sachez que inaugurée le 30 septembre 95
le scarabée la salle du scarabée fête
ses 20 ans du 25 septembre au 18
septembre
venez profiter de l'exposition dans le
hall du scarabée à la verrière un retour
en images sur les plus beaux moments de
la salle accompagné d'une sélection de
documents et d' affiches dédicacées
collector vingt ans déjà que le scarabée
accueil sur scène talents connus et
reconnus artistes en devenir et
chanteurs amateurs pour réjouir un
public intergénérationnel
je pense notamment à alain leprest qui
voilà qui était en concert au scarabée
quelques mois avant son décès et on
garde un souvenir vraiment très ému de
ce concert-là il ya des vraies
rencontres avec les artistes
il ya des choses beaucoup plus drôle on
a notamment des je me rappelle une
équipe jeune public s'est retrouvé
bloqué par la neige et qui a dormi au
scarabée
voilà donc on accueille pour
m'accueillir aussi des artistes lors de
conditions climatiques un peu
particulière et ça reste aussi une
soirée très agréable en très bon moment
de partage
nour ali akin tiers et aran merci et je
rappelle que l'on pourra retrouver le
vendredi 2 octobre à la merise le
spectacle d'improvisation de la
compagnie déclic théâtre qui opposera la
jeune génération aux anciens et le 14
octobre au palace à paris salle de 1000
places pour le spectacle de thierry tard
à un talon aiguille écran pour bruno
bachot surtout à la jean bart et et de
barres du jour voilà vous pouviez pas ce
que sont les auteurs voilà c'est dit et
lionel rousseau qui aussi le parti de
nos sponsors très bien voilà et
maintenant entretien avec le groupe
electro deluxe qui se produisait sur la
scène de la batterie et à guyancourt
vendredi soir c'est un entretien signé
wilfried richy
les images de william l ils sont une
demi douzaine il se prénomme thomas
jérémy galarneau ou encore à james eux
ce sont les membres d'électro de luxe
cinq albums à leur actif depuis 2001 le
dernier date de 2013 dans sa version
deluxe justement ils se produisent ce
soir sur la scène de la batterie à
guyancourt et nous les avons rencontrés
pour kiev
bonjour les trop de luxe bonjour à
thomas à gaël et à jérémy donc trois des
membres de la formation vous allez
procéder à la balance dans quelques
minutes c'est une salle un petit peu
plus petit ici par rapport à ce que vous
avez pu le faire vous avez fait des gros
festivals il n'ya pas longtemps encore
vous l'appréhendez comment le concert de
ce soir dans une salle comme ça plus
intimiste peut nous en fait on adore les
clubs on adore cette configuration de
salle de 500 places ont c'est vrai qu'on
a la chance de faire des beaux festivals
et on a eu la chance l'année dernière de
faire l'olympia
mais on continue à faire beaucoup de
clubs parce que l'on aime cette
proximité avec le public ça permet de
tester des choses c'est exactement ce
soir on va d'ailleurs carrément essayer
des nouveaux morceaux qu'on a répété
hier
donc c'est tout neuf tout frais du
public ce soir à me servir de cobaye un
petit peu on a voulu intégrer à notre
set qui est déjà très huit autres héros
des deux nouveautés pour c'est la
meilleure façon pour
pour les jauger les morceaux pour savoir
quel retour on aura sur ses morceaux
pour clarifier les choses pour ceux qui
connaissent pas votre univers influences
jazz rap soul et puis malgré le nom
electro deluxe parce que l'électronique
il ya beaucoup de musique les vrais
instruments sur scène décrit pour
notamment venir un petit peu à
contre-courant aussi de ce qui se fait
pourquoi c'est devenu à contre-courant
c'est à dire c'est que nous on a
l'habitude de dire être de lui que
c'était un groupe de musique quoi ça
avec des instruments d une basse une
batterie des cuivres et on a constaté
qu'on est en devenait marginal dans les
festivals notamment qu'on fait
où il ya beaucoup de projets électro qui
ceux qui sont en concert mais voilà nous
c'est devenu notre originalité
on remet ça
à
je
autre de luxe qui est dans sa deuxième
vie en fait là puisque l'arrivée du
chanteur 2010 chanteur qui n'est pas là
encore qui sera bien sur scène
j'espère qu'ils vont arriver crispés
travail qui sera là avec vous la
rencontre juste pour revenir sur ça pour
expliquer cette sa naissance de la
deuxième vie du groupe electro deluxe
c'est quoi un hasard 2010 c'est un très
très grand hasard c'est à dire qu'il ya
trop de luxe jusqu'à la rencontre avec
james copley fonctionner comme beaucoup
de groupes avec ce qu'on appelle des
featurings des invités sur les disques
on a plusieurs invités rappeurs
chanteurs chanteuses et sur scène on a
en prenez ce qui était disponible
on avait vraiment envie d'une figure de
proue pour notre musique quelqu'un qui
l'incarné qu'il la défende tous les
jours qui intègre le groupe ne s'était
pas qu'au hasard y avait une volonté
d'avoir fait un chantage mais on
galérait a trouvé vraiment on avait
beaucoup de mal à trouver et puis un
jour on a entendu parler d'un chanteur
qui avait fait des siennes dans un
karaoké de séminaires et une copine
radio j'ai vu un chanteur chante est
incroyable je crois que le graet
américain je les filme et m'a montré la
vidéo et on a trouvé ça incroyable et on
l'a appelée est venu tout de suite il
était du coup pas du tout chanteur qui
bossait pour une marque de fringues et
on a halluciné
l'homme et moi je pressentais en
lui-même et ne change rien c'est parfait
s'en sort plutôt bien son sort il a
vraiment ça dans le sang il est d'une
famille de chanteurs mais lui même avait
choisi une toute autre voie
chacun a amené à mener sont sa couleur
et sa sa couleur à lui il a il a ramené
avec tout ça tout ça culture tous sont
tous sont baghran de cuisses de pasteur
lance au malawi avant avant tout est ce
que c'est
c'est un comédie avant tout ça veut dire
qu'on peut pas rester assis à un concert
électro c'est impossible c'est
impossible on peut pas il fait il est y
communique sa son énergie à tout le
monde
ce
voilà
ça
c'est dur
un peu plus
e
l'album et le la scène ces deux choses
différentes et souvent commence par
l'album dans l'ordre et on se dit qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire de mieux
après donc on reprend l'album on leur
travail on le retourne en fonction de la
réaction des gens et puis avec
l'expérience des concerts on arrive à
ficeler un spectacle quoi dernier album
c'était 2013 une version deluxe
justement de l'album vous travaillez sur
le prochain justement en testant des
morceaux ce soir un petit peu voilà on
est en pleine phase de composition
d'écriture de répétition décès comme on
a dit on va jouer des morceaux ce soir
on a on a un album en préparation qui
sortira l'année prochaine
d'accord il y avait des morceaux avec un
site aussi notamment j'ai lancé les huit
assaillants tôt si oui ben l'oncle soul
la prochaine collaboration ce sera quoi
ça on peut pas le dire ses secrets mais
c'est vrai on a toujours des envies dans
la question plutôt le swing de duke
ellington bibloc de charlie parker ou le
groupe vial luis delis si on peut faire
un groupe avec l'étroite serait bien ce
serait sympa
moi je dirais le col jazz de miles davis
à comprendre très bien merci beaucoup
mais creux de luxe merci mon concert
pour ce soir et dans une continuation
aussi puisqu'il ya d'autres dates elles
sont retrouvés sur le site internet du
groupe
merci
non
tout de suite votre rubrique cinéma que
pensez-vous des films à l'affiché cette
semaine vos avis au micro d' elodie
moigne très bon film passé deux heures
peut penser à vos soucis est vraiment
vous rigolez en même temps c'est un
petit peu un film madame à thème un
message est donc vous pouvez penser à
part certaines choses et puis vous en
même temps vous rigolez vous passer un
bon moment tu étais divertissant et il
ya beaucoup d'espoir et d'amour à
l'intérieur donc c'est vraiment
intéressant
j'ai vraiment aimé ça mais c'était très
très bien un petit peu triste par an par
moment parce que bon on se demande si ça
arrive à s'en sortir notre petit payer
l'atelier a rigolé mais enfin c'est
drôle mais tout autant tout autant
touchant que drôle voilà
écoutez moi je sais pas s'il s'en
remettront et l'un et l'autre l'avenir
le dira je dirais que c'est un film
psychologique
il ya une tension une tension énorme il
ya de la violence très forte violence
des courts instants mais très très fort
après la fin nous laisse un peu sur nos
sols cette semaine c'est cyril haddad de
l'espace noir et des clayes-sous-bois
qui nous donne son coup de coeur sur les
sorties cette semaine le coup de coeur
de l'espace philippe noiret et le film
the program réalisé par stephen frears
le film nous entraîne dans le plus grand
scandale de l'histoire du sport le
démantèlement du programme de dopage qui
a fait de l'enceinte font qu'une légende
de la gloire à l'humiliation de
programme retrace le parcours de la star
du tour de france a pris un véritable
thriller
ce film nous plonge au coeur de cette
fois l'anc est passionnant et
magistralement réalisé au programme 6 am
sont des podiums du tour de france jusqu
au déshonneur entre images d'archivés et
reconstitution soignée
il en ressort un champion à la
personnalité opaque
je suis l'athlète le plus contrôlé la
planète
je n'ai jamais été contrôlé positif à
des produits améliorant les performances
il fait de votre petit sport européen un
événement international
s'il ment pendant les courses sait qu'il
nous ment a nous aussi
personne ne m'aura l'acteur ben foster
n'a eu que six semaines pour entrer dans
la peau du personnage sa performance
éblouissante constitue l'un des atouts
majeurs du film the programme est
proposé en version originale et en
version française cette semaine à
l'espace philippe noiret et avant de
nous quitter je vous propose quelques
dates à noter dans vos agendas le projet
michel le montana samedi 3 octobre à 20h
à l'estaminet de la verrière
oldelaf et alain berthier évoque avec
tendresse et passion les plus belles
heures du génie méconnu michel montana
au travers d'un colloque festif et
poignant mec spectacle de philippe
torreton et edward perraud au prisme
d'elancourt samedi 3 octobre à 21h
spectacle en forme de récital centré sur
la fulgurance des textes du poète maudit
allain leprest et enfin jeudi 8 octobre
à 20h30 à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt retrouver la double
inconstance avec la compagnie roland
furieux ou marivaux révèle avec élégance
la confusion des sentiments leurs
ambivalences ainsi que leur éprouvante
drôlerie fin du kiosque pour cette
semaine l'émission à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet
je vous retrouve avec plaisir mercredi
prochain très bonne soirée à tous